as movement restrictions across Israel
are tightened in response to the corona
virus in ultra-orthodox neighborhoods
the message has struggled to get through
few here have a television let alone the
internet and many rely on community
newspapers for information last week a
mass funeral procession for a rabbi in
the Tel Aviv suburb of Bnei Brak caused
nationwide anger a public flouting of
rules banning mass gatherings after
weeks during which some rabbis were
contradicting government orders
encouraging schools and synagogues to
carry on as normal
police toughened their response making
several arrests some have been abused
called Nazis one ambulance crew was
attacked with rocks what we are dealing
with is a small percentage of ultra
religious extremists who are not paying
attention and not listening and also
receiving the information in a delay
they're a week behind Israel's 1 million
strong ultra-orthodox community lives
and often parallel life modernity in
government mainly met with distrust
large families often subsist on welfare
payments to men whose sole task is to
study religious texts and who also
receive exemptions from serving in the
army videos showing extreme behavior by
a minority within the community have
stoked a resentment already present
among the mainstream the main question
towards the future is whether within the
community will be voices that until now
we didn't hear enough that we say ok we
want to protect our community but we
also belonged to the state authorities
talk about a growing acceptance of the
seriousness of the situation in
communities such as this one and an
improvement in the adherence to the new
rules
certainly this major Junction inside me
assuring an ultra-orthodox neighborhood
in West Jerusalem is far less busy than
usual but they also talked about the
delay in the community's response and
the damage already done as a result
neighbor awkward just 2 percent of
Israel's population accounts for 14% of
confirmed infections nationally one
health care executive estimates nearly
40% of its residents have the disease
Jim we have decided to reduce to the
minimum necessary access and egress from
Bnei Brak and the other areas to avoid
infection
the Prime Minister himself is now back
in isolation after the ultra-orthodox
Health Minister tested positive for the
disease Netanyahu had only just been
cleared after his advisor on
ultra-orthodox Affairs contracted the
virus for all the recent videos sparking
anger one has been welcomed an
ultra-orthodox man berating a prayer
group for breaking the rules calling
them murderers the fear is that this
community whose leaders treated the
disease most likely is now the one
awaiting the heaviest toll Harry Fawcett
al Jazeera West Jerusalem